- Il a fallu trente ans
de recherches et quatre ans
d'essais cliniques, mais
la pharmaceutique anglaise
Glaxo Smith Kline y est
enfin parvenu.
- Ce vaccin, le Mosquirix,
combat la plus dangeureuse
des souches de cette terrible
maladie parasitaire, transportée
par des moustiques, qui tue
chaque année 400 000 personnes
en Afrique seulement,
dont 260 000 enfants.
La malaria peut réinfecter
le même individu une demi
douzaine de fois par année,
en causant des fièvres et
des diarrhées très sévères.
Dr MICHAEL LIBMAN, dir., Centre
maladies tropicales, McGill
- C'est une maladie importante,
il y a beaucoup de mortalité
surtout chez les enfants et
c'est important qu'on ait au
moins quelque chose et une
efficacité de 50 % est quand
même beaucoup mieux que rien.
- Le Mosquirix, qui est
administré en quatre injections,
a été testé sur 800 000 enfants.
Son taux d'efficacité contre
l'infection,
les hospitalisations et
les décès est bon, mais pas
spectaculaire comme celui
des vaccins anti COVID.
Par contre, avec l'ajout
d'un médicament antipaludique,
il peut faire une grande
différence.
- On essaie de mettre tout
ensemble, des moustiquaires,
vaccins, diagnostiques
et traitement rapides,
tout ça ensemble est nécessaire
pour vraiment contrôler
cette infection.
- Ce vaccin est également
le premier qu'on met au point
contre un parasite, ce qui
réprésente un grande victoire
scientifique.
- Un autre vaccin contre
la malaria est présentement
en essai clinique, également en
Afrique. Il offre une protection
estimée à plus de 75 %.
- Le fait qu'on a aujourd'hui
un vaccin qui est approuvé,
c'est pas la fin de l'histoire.
- L'OMS espère maintenant que
le Mosquirix soit approuvé
rapidement par les gouvernements
et offert gratuitement
aux populations.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, M